So the question that I'm going to pose to you
is the following, in an RPC, there is a
client call, followed by the server procedure execution, and
then the returning the results to the client. How
many times does the kernel copy stuff from the
user address spaces into the kernel, and vice versa?
And I want you to focus on the question
a little bit more carefully. I said, the entire
interaction, going from the client call, to server
execution, and returning results back to the client,
the whole package in order to execute an
RPC. How many times does the kernel copy
stuff from user address spaces into the kernel
buffers, and vice versa? Meaning, from the kernel
buffers, back out to the user address spaces. Is it done once? Is it done twice?
Is it done three times? Or four times?